[Music]  with the lifespan able to reach as old  as 69 these iguanas can live as long as  humans  this is the grand cayman blue iguana  found only in grand cayman the largest  and westernmost of the cayman islands  their blue skin becomes more prominent  when establishing territory when other  iguanas are nearby  males turn especially bright blue during  breeding season but their blue skin  isn't their only defining feature they  have striking red eyes and excellent  vision which enables them to notice  shapes and movement at long distances  listed as endangered due to human  activity habitat loss and being preyed  upon by free-roaming predators such as  dogs cats and rats  these beautiful blue lizards face an  uphill battle against extinction this is  the grand cayman blue iguana  [Music]  you